tutti ragazzi di questo video sarò
quello lì che fai video stati sud erano
arrivati al capitolo 9 che ciò qua sotto
la mia testa però non si vede lo stesso
perché coperto avevamo fatto quel casino
della miniera tutto il bordello casinò è
adesso vediamo di portare a termine la
faccenda io in realtà credo che mia
moglie si è morta se l'è cercata anche
un po lei se vogliamo proprio fare
quelli siamo in un pozzo salve beh
questo è chiaro è la chiara
rappresentazione di chi perde la testa
nel per far favi jason sono incatenato
mi devo tagliare il braccio ma veramente
richiamo che partenza è ma veramente di
tutto gliele braccio per togliermi da
sto tizio no vabbè ma toglie la manetta
non tagliati braccio sei pazzo perché
sono ammanettata soddisfa anno taglio il
suo allora va beh ma allora va bene sono
un po pirla perché veramente credevo di
dover tagliare il mio però fa niente
questa allora ragazzi
masterchef prendiamo la mano la mettiamo
in pentola come si deve allora emilia
una pentola c'è un secchio va bene anche
il secchio va bene un po d'acqua e del
sale grosso 10 minuti come sono finiti
in un pozzo forse devo lanciare la
pietra che fa cadere il secchio può
essere bene stephen curry esatto occhio
madonna sembra rimasta pietra in testa
sono schifato posso posso fare climbing
sulla catena immagino esatto lasciano a
casa mia ma come veramente sento nati a
casa raga credo non sono sicuro questo
va il polso di che ci è vicino a casa
mia
sono convinto di questo ritorna in casa
va bene a non sono in quella del della
spia o che allora faceva niente torniamo
via e sci come ci sono finito nel pozzo
da spiegatemi non ha un senso recharge
unica house
devo capire se mia moglie ancora vivo se
schioppa tosse l'hanno presa quelli che
mi cercano
c'è ancora capito mi sono quanto sono
lontano da casa non so controlliamo su
google non mi ricordo la direzione di
kasami area ecco trovata trovata a posto
e appunto perché sento che sei stupido
non è colpa di tua moglie è colpa tua se
tua moglie la sorella ci sono quelli
pervertiti che ti toccano la famiglia
non scappare la ragazzini tolgono
camminare vi giuro non sono pazzo tesoro
sei ancora viva tesoro mare ma il mio ci
sono poliziotti che ti hanno importunata
cosa del genere
amore talk to m non sappiamo neanche
dove ogni volta che torno in casa non
sappiamo dove come bene
l'ultima volta era qua non equa tanto
non mi ha neanche risposto quindi
immagino che o fa la finta tonta anche
se di sopra a mare
madonna che musica brutta a noi cola
amore è stato qua di nuovo
ok
e allora ho fatto fuori un tizio che era
un supereroe in una miniera poi sono
finiti non posso stato il dettagliato e
braccio a 1 è sono mi sono hanno
applicato sulla catena però tutto a
posto devo fatturare zia come a milano
si dice fattura fatturati che ha
fatturato sfiga fatturato e poi la
famiglia basta ok
comunque lei è incazzata con me e c'ha
ragione perché la lascio sempre parola
find the place espande fotografie e lo
so dove e questo può infatti anche nello
scorso episodio non capivo cosa servisse
ma questo è il coso dove devo mettere
una specie di eccolo quindi ho trovato
qualcosa per i perché erano una vita che
1 per il milan se quale 64 avanti dio
quindi mettiamo 1864
ok allora 1860 che era già quello
incredibile bingo ma va bene
apriamo una granata santa quelle che
usano in worms a sembra che possa essere
posizionato da qualche parte ok gatling
dei hayden rooms the leader loan
praticamente qua c'è una stanza nascosta
no che sta sotto l'ufficio però non ho
capito come ficcarmi c dentro euro per
infilare qualche parte mi si apre acqua
che pirla meraviglioso voi basta
laterali sul burqa pu
basta tirarmi giù la mano in tutto
questo però fa niente stanza nascosta
prego che cos'è questo posso ma va detto
la vedevi da fuori sostanza perché non
si è mai accorto che c'è una stanza
nascosta nave si vedeva da fuori
la finestra ma dio va beh eccoci
sempre ovunque e so già qua non esistono
gli smartphone tutti pezzi di carta ok
allora persona tornassi indietro nel
tempo
apri la porta c'è qualcuno a testa
derulo cioè nessuno ha persi fido
gustare non c'è nessuno mi avete mentito
ma mi tirano di con le sprangate in
faccia
io lo sapevo tratto come è possibile ha
bussato la porta dall'interno come tu
come spiega poi sempre back in time
perché è uno switch tra penombra e
amnesia sto gioco o jeffrey swann to
maria sounds maria maria devo andare
alla casa di maria perché chi fa la spia
come si suol dire vabbè dai sta cosa
usata e riusata però fa niente macché no
ragazzi qualcosa nell'acqua a mi sta
facendo male
madonna ha posto come se non fosse
successo niente fa nulla ma che o no ma
c'è qualcosa nell'acqua che può
uccidermi quindi non entrò nell'arco va
bene ok madonna che bar curi stati
dedicati a maria dove andare ma da maria
d'agnano da maria che problema c'è
tornato nel coso per la luce che
dall'alto non la uso mai a questo punto
c'è 64 fiammiferi 65
secondo me è meglio utilizzarli perché
non li uso mai a trovare finito il gioco
li tengo tutti alimentario per quanto
faranno le piste inside 2
something in the water qualcosa di
grosso
madonna che vuoi che faccia posso tirare
l'accendino nell'acqua volendo oppure me
ne sbatto facevo finta di andare alla
madonna ne sbatto me ne sbatto ehi ehi
mamma mia
lui la madonna non ragazzi orribile
beccare proprio il momento giusto sono
io
tutto a posto non ci skies devo provare
a correre come un puledro non ce la farò
mai
però io ci provo no madonna ragazzi
fatto una cagata o tramite gatto fatta
una cagata una cagata negata una cagata
un aggregato nagata ce la fa proprio lui
sono più lenti quello che pensavo c'è un
secchio
ecco forse col secchio per farmi capire
che posso distrarlo ho capito ma dove
vado anche solista giu perfetto o aiuto
madonna il casinò ho provato a distrarlo
ma non so quanto ci sono riuscito ci
sono riuscito molto bene ma è che
bordello e modo di tornar teniamoli
teoricamente ok perfetto
ottimo il coach è una porta chiusa
dai che ansia l'hack è male
porco demonio ha morso il culo però a
posto non posso tradurre la ragazza è
tutto poco felice in questo gioco quindi
facciamo finta di niente signora maria
buongiorno come va la vedo bene oggi
molto allegra mi scusi allora venga un
attimo ma scusi ma che accoglienza e
questa come far scomparire quando vuole
e ciò che ogni volta la vorrei avere io
questo lo vorrei avere io sto potere ma
sai che bello
dopo quando nel ticino alle balle la
gente poco pouf e scompari bellissimo ci
provo
ce l'ho fatta madonna ha visto gioco poi
devo crederci perché se non impossibile
allora li posso ancora un po più
distante addirittura a proprio non mi
puoi prendere mai gol ma come minimo vi
prende e me lo merito pure perfetto
madonna
quanto dura specie madonna che kakà non
l'ho visto non lo vedo non so dove sia
vabbè coro
sono morto tira tira tira tira tira tira
tira tira tira tira tira tira tira tira
ok a posto incredibile quarto tempo per
tirare una leva che poi non sono stato
anche capace di farlo subito eccola
sfondata in tempo zero panieri rocce
devo andare lì sotto io non sto capendo
madonna rega che calino però ancora una
capito dopo otto ore che lancio pietre
non ha ancora capito che se il lancio di
pietre e per distrarlo va bene entra
veloce che c'è chi c'e dietro molto bene
perfetto con il demonio incastrato nel
duomo
porca [ __ ]
[Musica]